welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host definition aka the bat fan
who's more like black mask than Bruce
Wayne right now it's been very difficult
getting news updates on well anything
right now as there's one big story
that's taking up everyone's attention
and with dings and lockdown a lot of
movie productions have been delayed
I'd be like changing the catchphrase of
this show too sometimes bad time
sometimes bad Channel because we really
don't know when we'll be getting updates
but throughout this video we're going to
be discussing a new interview with
composer Michael Giacchino who has said
things about the film we'll also be
talking about the two-week delay on the
movie and whether we think it'll be
longer than that or not there may be
some spoilers here itself you want to go
into the film as blind as possible then
I highly suggest that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
to never miss a video and please drop a
like if you've been enjoying the
coverage so far without the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
our breakdown of the Batman okay so from
the 16th of March until the 22nd the
Batman was due to have some outdoor
public filming completed at st. George's
Hall in Liverpool this was going to be a
street scene at the location and that
would potentially involve the Batmobile
Matt Reeves did release the first look
at the car online the week before and in
keeping with the reveal of the suit
before the bike scenes were shot we can
assume that the Batmobile would be seen
racing through the streets extras
agencies had called out for cars with
left-hand drives and the studio had
slowly started to put things around the
area such as a police signpost for the
Gotham PD I just want to shout out
Daniel Swift on Facebook as he was
sending me messages and photos just his
production was ramping up and then he
kept me in the loop with it shutting
down
so yeah cheers to you he's a real Boy
Wonder of this episode it looked like it
was going to be a big scene and they
definitely had everything in place
however in wake of the outbreak Warner
Brothers did announce that production
would be delayed for two weeks we are
now at the halfway point of that and I
would be very surprised if production
resumed right after this coming week
only yesterday were schools and pubs
closed across the UK making us one of
the last countries to do so judging by
the other countries around the world and
their lockdowns I think that production
we'll be shut down for several weeks and
in the UK were pretty much just about to
hit the peak whereas others are sort of
in the middle with dealing with theirs
so if we are to hit the deadline of
production resuming on Monday the 30th
of March then that would mean that the
UK would have to have our lockdown
isolation period and then be back to
normality in the space of seven days
which I can't see happening I'll be
honest I can see it happening most
people with the virus are told to self
isolate for two weeks and as we are just
starting our period I can see it being
at least six weeks before things get
back in motion China are just passing
their peak now and they have been in
shutdown for that length of time they
had advanced warnings of the virus with
cases starting back in November so I
would be very surprised if the rest of
the world did it that fast time will
tell but I'm just happy that everyone's
taking the proper precautions and make
sure you stay safe at home everyone the
film's release state itself hasn't been
shifted and I do believe that if we are
back on track in two months then the
movie will be released in June 2021 as
stated
I'm really hoping sulcus because I don't
want to have to go back and change all
of the titles on my videos to Batman
2022
first of all problems right here Felton
productions tend to do as much as they
can as early as possible and then that
leaves time for reshoots and to polish
up the special effects in distribute it
though the delay will cause these
deadlines to be tighter it is still more
than likely that we will get the same
release date Matt Reeves is going to
have this time away to really figure out
all of the kinks and what won't work so
we will probably get rid of a lot of
things that aren't needed so that the
production itself can be more
streamlined production on the John
Carpenter classic the thing was delayed
due to poor weather and in this itís the
director worked on the script and well
look what we ended up gang I'm sure
Reeves will do the same and who knows we
may end up with an even better movie
because of it
now before we get into the composer's
thoughts on the film I just wanna let
you know we're giving away a free copy
of the Skywalker saga box set to one
random subscriber all you have to do to
be in with the chance of winning is like
the video subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts and the updates in
the comment section below the winners
gonna be chosen at random on the 15th of
April and the cell be shipped out from
then to ever gets the prize so best of
luck to everyone
takes part ok so Hollywood is pretty
much in lockdown now so any rumors and
plot leaks that you see over the next
coming weeks will likely be fake we saw
this yesterday with the rap reporting
that one know'm in 1994 could be getting
distributed digitally
however Warner Brothers quickly shut
this down there will be a lot of stories
like this over the next couple of weeks
I think where outlets are just so
desperate for clicks they just I just
make up anything and say that they have
insiders luckily for us though we do
have a lot of websites that are using
this time to reach out to people
specifically and kalida have just
launched a new program called collider
connected this live interview format has
been designed to keep fans up to date
with things by speaking to creators
directly their first guest was Michael
Giacchino aka the composer for the
Batman he's worked on films like Spider
Man homecoming Jurassic world and slowly
the musician is carving his way through
Hollywood by lending his talents to some
big projects Giacchino has already
confessed to being a massive Batman fan
and whenever you see him talking about
the project you can see that he's very
enthusiastic we're just gonna be
breaking down the key points in the
interview and what we can take from them
firstly he was asked what it was like
working with Matt Reeves and giacchino
said the following I felt total freedom
to do whatever I want Matt always agreed
this is our Batman this is our vision in
the same way that I always loved what I
still do about Batman comics and graphic
novels is that each of these artists
each of these authors they take their
own cracker what they want this to be
it's their version of Batman I love it
when I see a graphic novel of Batman in
the 1800s
to me that is cool I love that I'm not
the kind of person that says Batman must
always be this it's like no why it can
be whatever the artist wants to be and
it has over the years done that many
times over I love the idea of taking
something and just kind of doing our
version of it so it does look like they
are being experimental with the route
that they're taking on the character
Batman Gotham by Gaslight probably is
the eighteen hundred's Batman that he's
referring to and we can see this
referenced in the cowl
we know that the movie will be a murder
mystery and though there has been
confirmation it will be based on the
long Halloween it's also possible that
they could take
our tip notes from that book which is
also centered around the investigation
of Jack the Ripper and I know this
movie's inset in the eighteen hundreds
but who knows we may even get a slightly
updated adaptation of it
aka Romeo and Juliet so glad I could get
that in this video
when discussing what the new version of
the character could be he stated I think
the only thing I'd be allowed to say is
watch the teaser and then make your own
decision on this I do love it I think
what he's doing is really cool and it's
different and it feels fresh and the way
that I get excited when I see a new
graphic novel or a comic book coming out
with a new take on it it feels like that
so we will be getting a completely new
and different take on the Cape Crusader
that we haven't really seen before a
definitely thing that this is present in
not only the suit but also the car
itself I actually watched blade last
night and I got flashes of the new car
and the ride that the daywalker rolls
around in so it's clearly pulling from a
lot add the quarter bowels Gotham by
Gaslight the Arkham games and a lot more
influencing the suit and I think we're
in for a real great melding of a lot of
works now being a composer the
conversation quickly moved to the theme
and Giacchino stated that in the
pre-production process they decided to
really take ownership of the character
when discussing these choices he said
this was a great opportunity to from the
get-go say nope this is our Batman like
it or not this is what we're doing Matt
and I talked about this for a long time
obviously and last year after reading
the script I remember sitting down and
going oh I have an idea I have an idea
and I wrote that piece that is in the
teaser trailer and matt has had that too
it wasn't even done with the orchestra
or anything so then he had been using
that in every single one of his
presentations at Warner Bros he would
put it behind and be like all right here
are the costumes and here the thing
here's the music and here the thing so
when it came time to release the teaser
he was just like what we have to put it
with the music so from that statement we
do know the theme we've heard is a demo
version and that we will be getting an
orchestra version of it at some point in
the film Giacchino also stated that they
are currently working on more music
whilst production is shut down and that
they are watching back certain things
with the instrumentals added over that
pop when discussing this the composer
said Matt and I love it we watch it we
have a lot of fun with it which makes us
feel like kids again I did go over and
record that for that we recorded a bunch
of other music as well for it a bunch of
themes and things that nobody has heard
yet
but they'll all be popping up as the
film gets under way again and starts
getting back to production life gets
back to normal hopefully soon
and finally when talking about Pattinson
in the Cowell Giacchino said the
following Robert Pattinson is just a
fantastic actor and I'm thrilled to see
a minute I feel like that is such a
crazy great choice for Batman and people
will realize that once they see it so
there are a lot of things to look
forward to and it really feels like
we'll be getting a completely new and
unique depiction that pulls from a lot
of Batman comics and law though things
are delayed I'm still really excited for
the movie and I can't wait to see what
they pull out the bag in the next couple
of months now obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on these updates and what
you want to see in the next couple of
weeks I'm gonna be keeping my eyes close
to the updates and if any big news comes
out then you'll be the first to hear it
make sure you say look to the channel
and also please give us a thumbs up if
you enjoyed the video you missed our
last video then please check it out
after this as we go over the Firefly
casting rumors and debunk the one that
states Johnny Depp is playing the Joker
do you want to support the channel from
as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below you
get access to content early and can also
suggest video topics and breakdowns we
massively appreciate it it goes a long
way to helping videos like this get made
you want to come chat to us after the
show either follow us at definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next
take care peace
you